well there definitely is a culture of
celebrity and a fascination with it and
I think generally the media is very
interested in cases involving
celebrities I do represent a lot of
women who have been hurt by the rich the
powerful and the famous many of whom are
celebrities and so while the it we're on
the the end of representing essentially
the underdog the typical person against
the celebrity now celebrities have their
highly paid legal mouthpieces they have
their publicists they have their
promoters their managers their agents
various and sundry hangar honors
groupies fans and others who will be
supportive of them because celebrities
have often been in millions of living
rooms through television or the internet
or through feature films often they are
well-liked well-known and supported by
many and we're taking the person who is
not known at all typical person but who
may have been hurt by the arrogance and
a sense of entitlement and privilege the
celebrity has and inflicted an injustice
on our clients so it is a very David and
Goliath type of situation where the
David or davita versus Goliath but I'm a
guerrilla fighter that's gue are and I
am very happy to take on these battles
where there's legal merit to the claim
and what we want to do is we want to
equalize the power and win as much
justice as is possible for a client who
has been the victim of injustice by
celebrities celebrities are used to
being able to get whatever they want do
whatever they want whenever they want
however they want they're often
surrounded by yes people who don't
exercise their judgment to say no to the
celebrity or even suggest
they might be doing something wrong or
even illegal because those people who
surround them and their entourage
sometimes are afraid that they will be
risking their own jobs if they anger the
celebrity by telling them the truth I'm
in the business of letting the
celebrities know what the truth is that
we know it that what they've done is
wrong they need to be accountable for it
they need to compensate my clients in an
appropriate case if they have hurt them
and if there's legal merit to the claim
and so that's what we do and this is
shocking to most celebrities they're not
used to being challenged at all and
especially by a woman and they have
generally underestimated the people they
have hurt not realized that those people
do know enough to contact me or another
attorney and you know that they have
rights and will exercise them in an
appropriate case so I don't know why
they should be shocked i've been
practicing for 35 years it would not be
a surprise to most people that a lot of
women who've been hurt by celebrities
would come to me but somehow sometimes
these celebrities are just in total
shock or expressed surprise but I'm a
practical person they know that
unreasonable that they can resolve
things with me if they're going to be
people who are knowing how to open up a
dialogue about if they want to battle it
to the end I'm there for the battle
because they can because they do and
because in most cases they get away with
it so where they can be challenged
should be challenged and where we have
evidence to support our claim we will
challenge them if our client wants us to
because we're not afraid of them I've
challenged government I've challenged
big corporations I've challenged small
businesses I've challenged wrongdoers
famous infamous and not known at all
batterers killers discriminators sexual
harasses those who sexually abused
children many many people and you know
I'm not in fear I know we're doing what
is right we're standing up for typical
people who would otherwise have no voice
and have no power I would not otherwise
have anyone to advocate for them or
enforce their rights so they can set the
celebrities can say and do whatever
they're going to say and do but we're
going to do what we need to do that is
legal and peaceful to vindicate the
rights of our clients